people ask us why we're here and quite
simply we think that basketball is the
greatest sport in the world three-time
NBA world champion Chicago Bulls
congratulations what a legacy David
Stern leaves behind David Stern is a
true legend of our game the Celtics and
the Lakers treated the world to a battle
between the two best basketball teams
congratulations the great champions it's
amazing this man his vision the NBA
needed a heavy hand and he was the heavy
hand to guide us to the point where we
are today
he understood how to promote the game
the team and the superstars all at one
time and that's when the lead went to a
whole nother level the country is
getting interested very much again in
the NBA people are beginning to focus on
the players and how great they are used
in Rockets select Hakeem Olajuwon David
Robinson Charles Barkley Kevin Garnett
Dwayne Wade Anthony Davis the Orlando
Magic selects Shaquille O'Neal it was a
great man I knew in 1991 when I shook
his hand as I'm finally here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations
Tim Duncan
James in a league of very valuable
players you are the most valuable as
commissioner for the league he was still
one of the best friends of all the
players I'm gonna conduct the draft in
this ours I mean if anybody can do you
came all right okay what are you
laughing at
he was truly a patriarch and a father
figure in the sport of basketball
because of HIV virus that I have I will
have to retire from the Lakers this is a
very courageous heroic person and a
heroic act Commissioner Stern stood
right by me I needed that support and
love at that time three months ago he
announced his retirement but he was
voted by the fans as one of the starting
guards for the Western Conference Stars
the only thing that could help me if was
to play basketball
Commissioner stars that I'm on let him
play Magic King / z
three
magic you're the most valuable player
you're a most courageous person the
moment is yours
congratulations after he gave me that
trophy not just cried and just said
thank you if it probably wasn't for that
moment I probably wouldn't be sitting
here now thank you to these great
players these very great players these
extraordinary athletes for thrilling the
world the 215 countries and territories
that saw this game I think mrs. turn
will be remembered as someone who helped
make the game more popular worldwide he
was ahead of the curve every time you
see a foreign player in the league you
can take David dirt footage when I got
roughed up the groosalugg came to me and
said would like to take a trip with you
transferred I was like whoa this man was
about to changing the fence of rewarded
to the game of basketball
basketball is an incredible teaching
tool for teamwork on the court and about
life off the court Commissioner Stern
took it as a priority you know not just
to give back to the communities but also
to take an interest in the individual
over the years his work impacted a great
number of lives is truly a pioneering
he's changed women's basketball forever
and the fact that so many young girls
around our country are dreaming to play
in the WNBA and he allowed us to have
that dream he was a true icon of the
sport he made two in v8 what it is then
we should all be thankful Dave Lee will
go down as I think the greatest sports
Commissioner of all time as legacy they
won't forever
[Music]